Jesus his real name is Yeshua first of
all he was a real person that did exist
I've been to the house where he grew up
uh in Egypt if you look at this Sumerian
Tablets you discover that these virgin
births were not unusual they were
experimenting in these types of and
vitro fertilization techniques where
they would take an egg and put it in the
womb not their egg another uh woman's
egg I think he's half human half
Atlantean that's my personal opinion
well he himself said he's not of this
world which means he's an alien okay
that's the definition I believe that he
was a chosen one and I think the real
mission was to bring a certain level of
Christ Consciousness which existed
before Jesus Christ that terminology
ever came to be where they're all
knowing all loving they're they're the
epitome of service to others and
unconditional love for for one another
and Jesus never said he was going to
return He said the Christ would return
and he's talking about the Consciousness
coming back to this planet and raising
everyone up to a higher level and
bringing back a new golden age